if there is one movie that underground
independent film hipsters are hoping is
good it's this one The Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo so The Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo stars Daniel Craig and the
girl from the social network who was
also in that as The Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo and Daniel Craig's a reporter who
has a really keen eye on investigation
so he gets hired to solve a murder that
was like 40 years old so he gets the
help of the girl with the dragon tattoo
who also has an absurd talent for
solving crime or at least looking into
stuff and hacking like to an absurd
degree she's like autistic I mean that
chick who plays her she's a really good
actress props to her she was awesome and
Daniel Craig was really good too but you
know he's gonna be good there is no way
that someone's gonna be like oh yeah the
movie was good but the weak link dude
Daniel Craig you're not going to hear
that any more than you're ever gonna
hear and the Oscar goes to Megan Fox for
Jennifer's body - not gonna happen ever
and thing about this movie is it was so
hyped up everyone's like oh Jeremy do
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo girl with
the Dragon Tattoo like the Lord and
Savior himself come back to earth in
movie form and he is the girl with the
dragon tattoo the movie and is it it is
no Jesus I'm not that it's a bad movie
or anything like that it's just the
movie doesn't live up to the hype for me
I mean although the movies well shot and
really well acted it's ultimately a
crime investigation movie and that's it
I've seen movies like that before is
like a crime we need to solve it all
right let's go solve that crime and it's
pretty much the girl with the dragon
tattoo with a main character that has a
lot of damage there so it really doesn't
cover it the word damaged in fact
calling her damaged it's like calling
Hitler a prick yeah it's true but it
just doesn't really hit the gravity of
the situation
and you can argue that it's not about
the crime it's about the girl with the
Dragon Tattoo but it doesn't feel like
that it feels like it's about the crime
until the last 20 minutes of the movie
where it's not about the crime anymore
and of course there's a whodunit aspect
it's like alright who did this crime and
I was thinking I don't know who did it
but if the movie is cliche it's gonna be
that person right there because that
person in a cliche movie would be the
killer and that person was all I'm
saying is all I'm saying I like the tone
I like the acting I like the characters
but all in all the movie was a 2
and 40-minute whodunit it's not like one
of the best things I've ever seen it's
okay so when the pros with the cons I
will say this movie is a two ative falls
with good acting now just names good act
and there you have it well people love
it yes will people not yes well either
be right or wrong sure yeah spoiler
alert over here there's a rape scene in
this movie and it's like the most
graphic want to ever seen I don't like
rape scenes it just the I don't like him
they put me in a bad mood I was in a bad
mood for like 15 solid minutes while
watching this movie who's the rapist
this dude it looks like wicket from Jedi
he's a creepy bastard but of course
there is balance in the world but still
it doesn't make up for it right the girl
with the Dragon Tattoo have you seen the
original have you seen this one are they
different I'd like to know so comment
below let me know my film hipster
fanatic subscribers because if you're
subscribed to me you're not really
hipster you know why because YouTube is
pretty mainstream let you soak in that
for a while and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more